[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
the Tony Michaels podcast real and raw
political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
so Mitt Romney is just coming around to
the realization that the Republican
Party hates the Constitution
[Music]
hahaha
oh mate you could pitch you later
on he's both sides and [__] you know
everyone's excited that Mitt Romney's
finally uh turning against the
Republican party here
buddy both sides it he still capitulates
to the idea that the Republican party is
still is still a viable party in our
democracy
even though even though he says that his
party does not believe in the
Constitution think about that for a
second we have a two-party system
the Constitution is the foundation of
our Democratic constitutional republic
and one of the party's leaders who who
by the way was the Presidential nominee
in the the year 2012 not but just over
10 years ago
is saying that that party doesn't
doesn't believe in the Constitution
I
again I I don't know what kind of alarm
Bells we gotta ring here that that
fascism is here folks I mean yesterday
we had Dr Rachel bittickoffer on giving
us the the rundown of this project 2025
I mean it's
it's 19 it's night the 1930s solution to
destroy our democracy
hello
thank McFly think
these things are not complicated it's
not it's not some big Grand conspiracy
it's point A to point B Republicans have
been fascist a fascist cult for a long
time now they're just saying all the
quiet Parts out loud
you know that you know the most
terrifying part
of Mitt Romney saying what he said
yesterday is that he has believed that
for a long time he didn't just come to
this realization overnight and he's been
you know dancing around this this idea
for a long time
but you know what Mitt Romney has voted
Time and Time and Time and Time Again
with the fascist Cult of Republican
party that they are who do not believe
in the Constitution
he's been voting with them
I mean the only two votes he didn't take
that the Republicans wanted him to take
was to not impeach Trump
history is going to tell a weird story
of Mitt Romney here just from his
statement yesterday
because again he capitulates to the
fascists by saying the both sides and
[__] I'm gonna show you the statement
that he put out officially and then
we're going to watch um some of his
press Gaggle that he had
in his office where he was answering
questions
and apparently his you know he's saying
that his party does not believe in the
constitution in his new book
and of course he's gonna try to be like
well I'm not saying the hope I'm just
saying certain people get the [__] out
of here man they're running the party
dude
we've seen it this week we're
the Speaker of the House
who is supposed to be the highest
ranking elected official right now in
the Republican Party think about this
in this country Kevin McCarthy this is
sad to even say out loud but Kevin
McCarthy is the highest ranking elected
Republican in the country
and he had to run out in front of
cameras and pretend like he's gonna
impeach Joe Biden because some [__]
chucklehead from Florida Matt gatz was
gonna make a statement
to try to try to take Kevin McCarthy out
of his seat of speaker
who's this who is the speaker
who is it Kevin huh
and then just days later
Mitt Romney's like my party doesn't even
believe in the Constitution
no [__] Sherlock
you don't you don't say
you don't say wow well
and the media just seems to be waking up
to this
well maybe maybe Mitt Romney's right
maybe Mitt Romney's what do you mean of
course he of course he's right
Jesus Christ we've been yelling and
screaming on this show for two goddamn
years longer
since Trump wouldn't concede after he
[__] lost
I've been yelling and screaming it that
they're a bunch of [__] Nazis
maybe the country come around this
and with this project 2025 stuff
folks that I don't know if you're taking
deep dives into this but
we're going to use it as the rake that
they're gonna step on to be quite honest
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna throw
that [__] rake right out in front of
them make them jump on that rake of the
project 2025 are you kidding me
the Heritage Foundation and every other
conservative Nazi Think Tank Nazi think
tanks
you don't come up with a document like
project 2025 to destroy our [__]
democracy from within
so that you can have a fascist theocracy
like they want in Florida and Oklahoma
and Texas and my state of Missouri
Tennessee
and on and on it goes in the red States
they want they want to have a theocracy
of fascist theocracy here in America
they hate democracy again Mitt Romney's
finally coming around to it but they
hate the Constitution yeah no [__] they
want to destroy the Republic like Hitler
destroyed the Republic
in Germany in the 1930s
and they're laying the blueprint out for
for all to see and you don't think I'm
gonna throw that rake in front of them
and make them step on it you goddamn
right we're going to
and it's becoming more clear as I have
said
in the past months
that these Trump trials are not the most
important thing
oh the media is going to be distracted
by each motion oh man every time every
time someone farts in Georgia
are coughs in the DC Court
our Canon makes a stupid decision down
in Florida or or she comes to her senses
and makes a decent decision
or maybe the Manhattan D.A or Tish James
something happens there they're going to
be distracted like a [__]
because folks
this project 2025
it's not about Trump because I've been
telling you Trump is not the disease
here Trump is a symptom of the disease
and that disease is American fascism
and they've been disguising it for
decades as conservatism and this fascist
cult is not going to stop until they
[__] succeed
they lost the culture wars that's why
they're trying to re-stoke them they're
trying to get us to go to war with them
on gay beer and [__] M M's with the
wrong shoes
and mermaids
all all in all in the push to convince
their sheep their flock
the democracy is bad
that authoritarianism is the answer to
wokeism
well we must stand strong for our
democracy because we have feckless [__]
like Mitt Romney that's right Mitt
Romney yesterday was not courageous in
making the statements that he made he
[__] quit folks he quit the fight
he was like you know what my party
doesn't believe in the Constitution
anymore I'm done
I'm weak I can't go on I can't win a
primary not gonna do it
[Music]
um
I'll let the Next Generation deal with
fascist
I'm too old I'll let the Next Generation
have a have a go at
getting rid of the fascists that I
capitulated to for decades
and that's what he's done
Mitt Romney's no hero
you think he's a hero because he took a
vote to impeach Trump twice you think
that makes him heroic
that's that's the [__] lowest bar
there is
he did the bare minimum
bare minimum Mitt Romney what he should
have said yesterday
and I would have a lot more respect for
Mitt Romney if he would have said this
not only is my party
against the Constitution but they are
going to war with democracy and they
want to destroy it and that is why I'm
leaving the Republican party today now I
should have left it years ago because
they do not believe in our Republic
anymore
they are they are Fascist through and
through there has been a Civil War in my
party and the fascists have won
so I'm no longer a member of the
Republican Party
and I don't I don't agree with the
Democrats on policy points but I will
support them because they will defend
democracy and the advancement of our
constitutional republic that is what he
should have said
no it's not what he said
he's a coward
just like the [__] rest of them
every one of these Republican Nazis
because Rachel bidikoffer said it really
well yesterday
there ain't no way there ain't no way if
they take over
if they take our government over with
this project 2025
that the majority of Americans are going
to stand against them it means danger
for your family for your children
for your future
it's dangerous [__]
Democrats are promoting Liberty Freedom
Choice Equity equality diversity
Republicans want to kill all of that and
anyone who supports it
[__] Bet On It
how do you think fascism ends
how do you think it ends
what what what do you think they're
gonna do
if project 2025 comes about they're
gonna completely gut the entire
administrative state in this in this
country
how do you think how do you think we
administrate policy
our laws
the rule of law will be dead there will
be no law and order it will only be
authoritarianism and they will use
unilateral power against anyone and
everyone that is a dissenter that is
what happens in a fascist state
I'm not being hyperbolic either
these are the [__] facts
go look this [__] up
and if you believe that that these right
Wingers
in these these [__] Nazi think tanks
and I'll go okay yeah a lot of these
think tanks may have not have been so
fascist in the past but they have won
they've won their Civil War that's the
Civil War that has been happening in our
country not with the country
inside the Republican party and the
fascists have won
they have the full range of power in the
Republican party and they're going to
use every single bit of it to overturn
our democracy
and who better to give it to them than
their feckless [__] cult leader Trump
he'll do anything they want
as long as they Wag the tail he'll be
the dog
you can damn well better bet that
he ain't got a choice really what is his
choice
play ball with the Nazis
be be there be The Cult leader that they
want that they so desire or go to prison
that's his choice
this country this country better wake up
to the truth fast
fast because it's not just about him
any one of these feckless idiots
these fascists could take this plan and
implement it
again to the words of Dr Rachel bidikov
for yesterday and if you didn't watch
that interview yesterday you need to go
watch it
and we are going to talk more and more
with Doc on this show about project
2025.
and I'm gonna go through that son of a
[__] line by line and I'm gonna give
you the comparisons I'm going to arm you
with the ammunition that you need
to to take the battle to the ballot
we have to mobilize the American people
and when we mobilize them they must
understand what these [__] want and
what their goals are
their goals are not democracy their
goals are not the Republic even the ones
that are like oh we don't live in a
democracy we live in a republic they
want to destroy the Republic you [__]
idiot even if you don't believe that
it's a democracy even if you're so
brainless she ain't got no brain cells
to rub together to understand that a
constitutional republic is a form of
democracy you stupid bastard
they want to destroy your Republic they
want to take you right away from you
authoritarianism is not going to stop
once you get it in a snowball going down
the hill
they're coming for your way of life
and we must mobilize the American people
with the understanding that this is the
vote that you are taking
all the way down the ballot folks not
just for the [__] president
that's the other thing we need to get
the American people to understand quick
fast and in a hurry [__] those trials
[__] the criminal charges [__] all that
[__]
oh that's great politicization and we
can make politics out of it but the key
here
is to get them to understand they're
going to take away your way of life
those schools that you got
you know the the soccer team that you
take your kids to each each week to
practice
oh the theater that you go to down the
street
the library where you get your books
the grocery store where you get your
[__] groceries
the church that you that you like to
attend
the community center that you so desire
to use
the parks
the public spaces
that life you know every single facet of
it gone
replaced
by the story of fascist
history gone wiped away
groups of people your countrymen your
community members gone
and sit here and [__] doubt me do it
do it
I dare you but if you're doubting me if
you're sitting here saying this is all
hyperbolic this is this project 25 thing
that's not what they want
is is full on fashion you're you're out
of your mind
if you can't see this is their plan
and it's their blueprint and Mitt
Romney's seat Mitt Romney sees it he has
he has been looking at it for a while
now
do you remember let's rewind for a
second do you remember Mitt Romney was
running in 2012
and he had to do this stupid thing
where he had to pretend to take the
endorsement of some [__] phony ass
billionaire
because because that billionaire was
running around talking about how Obama
needed to show his birth certificate do
you remember that
and you genuflected to that billionaire
and then when he lost and then that
billionaire the next go around became
the the billionaire again he's a fake
billion he's not really a billionaire
it's all [__] fraud it's all pretend
he's [__] broke as [__] and we're
gonna find that out in this [__] New
York trial with Tish James and if he
ain't broke yet he's gonna be
why do you think he's grifting like a
sumbitch
but remember the next go around he
became the nominee that guy that Romney
had a genuflect to
or pretend to their Nintendo won his
endorsement
you remember that because he oh he was
the he was the racist [__] wet dream
by talking about all that big black
scary guy who's the president United
States he's a Kenyan he didn't have a
person even though he did the guy never
had evidence we still haven't seen the
evidence of the birth certificate or the
investigation investigators that he sent
to Hawaii because they didn't exist
remember he he really liked judge Arpaio
in Arizona they were big buddies because
they were both birthers
trumping him on Trump pardoned him you
remember that hmm
all seems connected right
but I remember a day when Mitt Romney
with Jenny flag to Trump
yeah Mitt Romney voted for him probably
twice
probably twice even after he voted to
impeach him he probably voted for him
I mean I guess we'll never really truly
know maybe history will tell that story
you think Mitt Romney didn't know this
guy was dangerous in 2012
have you ever seen that where Trump
tried to pretend to endorse Mitt Romney
you ever you see that
it's awkward as [__]
Mitt Romney clearly does not even want
to stand next to that scumbag
and why would he
you know
why would an actual rich person want to
stand to someone who pretends to be rich
you know
Trump's totally beneath Mitt Romney but
he voted with him Time and Time and Time
Again capitulated to Trump
time and time and time again again even
after impeaching him the first time I
bet he voted for him in 2020 [__]
doubt me on that
provide your voting record MIT show us
the ballot
feckless
cowardice
capitulation that's all it is from Mitt
Romney
I mean I'm not gonna I'm listen Mitt
Romney's out of office are going to be
out of office he's not going to rerun as
a senator because he can't win a primary
he knows he can't win a primer in Utah
that's why he's leaving it ain't because
he's doing something courageous for the
country because he doesn't want to be an
old Senator get the [__] out of here
Mitt Romney wanted that seat until the
day he died
that's what he really wanted but he it's
not a reality
anymore he can't win the primary which
means he won't be the senator and he'll
be disgraced in that loss
just like all these other Republicans
that have retired early
why do you think some of these Senators
have continued to capitulate and give
fellatio to Trump like Lindsey Graham
and Chuck Grassley
as part of the plan of the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
Ling knew the plan
he knew the plan
he capitulated to Trump because he wants
to keep his seat
he doesn't want to get primary he wants
to be Senator until the day he dies
Mitt Romney wasn't willing to trade that
away for whatever it's worth I don't
think it's worth a lot really honestly
that's a bare minimum
that that Mitt Romney held up his oath
to defend our nation against enemies
foreign and domestic
I mean Jesus Christ Mitt Romney texts
Mitch McConnell
on two two days before January 6th he's
like hey January 6 gonna happen what are
you gonna do about it crickets
[__] crickets from Mitch McConnell
and we're gonna stand around pretend
that somehow Mitt Romney's a hero here
come on
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney knew January 6
is gonna happen he text Mitch McConnell
gets crickets and doesn't go to the
media
doesn't get out in front of a microphone
he's mitt [__] Romney for crying out
loud you don't think you don't think he
can attract a few flies to a Presser
especially if he was speaking out
against the guy who claims he won when
there's no evidence who is arranging a
coup the coup is a a foot
it was in full swing Mitt Romney
describes it in the text message
perfectly of the plan
how in the [__] is it that Mitt Romney
knew the exact plan
you think he guessed that [__]
no
they knew the [__] plan it was a plan
to overthrow your [__] country your
[__] democracy your Republic
to stamp all over your vote and your
rights and your Liberty in this country
he knew it
and it again it ain't because he guessed
Mitch McConnell wouldn't even give him a
message but not even a thumbs up you
know what I mean he could at least been
like thumbs up that message yeah cool
got you bro nothing
crickets
and the reason why is because Mitch
McConnell knew the plan too
they all did
just like they all know the plan going
forward project 2025 the the fascist
theocracy takeover
they literally want to give unilateral
power to the president of the United
States
the exact opposite of what we need in
this country frankly we need to take
more power away from the president I
don't care who the [__] it is
I don't care if it's a Democrat I don't
give a [__] if it's a republican we need
to give more power back to the Congress
where we have a say every two [__]
years
that's what we need to do
but
we're a long way from that
we have to just settle with saving our
[__] democracy first
so strap in get ready to engage because
this battle is going to be at The Ballot
Box next year
and it's gonna be a hell of a fight
folks
if they win
and I'm not just talking about the top
of the ticket
all the [__] way down
they can't wait
wait to make project 2025
a breeding ground in red States
Florida Alabama Georgia Louisiana
Texas
Tennessee Missouri
wherever wherever Republicans have a
Stranglehold wherever the minority
ideology has a Stranglehold on the
population within a border they're going
to try to Institute this project 2025
not just at the federal level
they're going to destroy Apartments
Departments of Education they're going
to destroy your Schools they're going to
destroy your hospitals your libraries
everything that this country has built
since its Inception
in perfectly at times
totally imperfect at times
oh God we have a
big stains on our history
but we can move forward with those
stains
we can acknowledge those things
acknowledge our weaknesses
our faults that we've had in the past
and change them that's called progress
but we only do that with our democracy
that is it
us the people we the [__] people the
government
not one authoritarian leader
not one person telling us what we can
and cannot do and what you should do
though is be here every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Facebook and twitch that's right YouTube
Facebook and twitch I stopped
broadcasting the Twitter [__] Twitter
I'm not gonna broadcast there anymore
big announcement
that's so [__] it's such [__]
over there oh my God
the the streaming platform's even worse
than it was
before they [__] it up for people like
Tucker
oh my God he's destroyed it it's
absolutely destroyed over there to
broadcast over there
I mean periscope's still the same [__]
but it's horrible so I'm not
broadcasting to Twitter anymore and it's
not because I don't want people on
Twitter not to see the show it just it's
[__] it's pointless
it's it's a waste of my time to even
push the button to be quite honest so
Facebook YouTube and twitch that's where
we're gonna broadcast and on the Discord
you must get in on the Discord it's
where the chat party never stops here
I'll put the link
in the chat that way you have it
let's see let's put the link in the chat
oh maybe
maybe I don't know
I got all kinds of things going on here
now let's put it in the it's let's put
it in the chat here you guys can go join
the Discord what you got to do is you
gotta verify when you go into the
Discord it's really easy it's not hard
you just go to the Welcome Center the
directions are right there it shows you
how to push the button to verify if you
can't verify it tells you the directions
on who to who to tag to get verified in
the in the Discord and tomorrow morning
we're going to do the second pre-show of
the Tony Michaels podcast in Discord
that's right tomorrow in the morning an
hour before the show come you gotta sign
up for patreon so go to
thetonymichaels.com that's
thetonymichaels.com
and you can sign up for patreon and come
join us tomorrow morning
in
the pre-show we haven't decided on a
name yet we're throwing them around you
know what I mean like we're throwing
them around this one maybe that one a
little bit here a little bit there
but tomorrow morning we'll talk before
the show last
last Monday this Monday uh we had the
very first pre-show it's very successful
we actually were talking about project
2025 we were talking about 911 because
it was 9 11 on the very first one but
tomorrow will be September 15th so I'm
sure we'll be talking about all kinds of
issues so go to thetonymichaels.com you
can subscribe to the Johnny michaels.com
for free up at the top you'll get
uh updates every single day
and then you go to patreon right here
and you can sign up for the 20 tier or
higher will get you in
the pre-show if you just sign up for any
patreon you go to the Discord and you
can you can have access to the private
patreon chat all the patreon members get
access to the chat so you can talk to
each other as patreon members but to get
the pre-show
and here's the thing you guys support
you guys have I can't believe it it
warms my heart because you guys have uh
supported this show and Gabe Sanchez is
what was that live you know today is
Thursday it's the third what was that
live you joined Gabe Tuesday and
yesterday he's so close to ten thousand
subscribers on his YouTube channel now
like just if he's not there already he
might be there already this morning I'm
not really sure but he was just just a
few away yesterday
so it's so it's so great that you guys
went over and you supported Gabe and you
should if you're not subscribed already
just go to the Tony michaels.com pan
down to the uh podcast links Gabe's
YouTube channel is right there click on
that and
subscribe to Gabe's YouTube channel you
can also be a member over there he's
monetized on his YouTube channel he's a
lot more careful than I am
he's a lot more careful than I am she
can become a member on his YouTube
channel to support Gabe there or you can
go to his patreon as well and just go to
his YouTube channel you'll find all
those links there too go watch if you
haven't watched what was that live go
watch and support Gabe and you guys have
there was like almost 1200 people
yesterday that showed up for a show
that's that's incredible
that's incredible and I want to thank
you so much the audience for supporting
Gabe Sanchez in his effort to further
that piece of content and get you guys
more and more stories the stories that
he can't get to in the what was that so
he does that into what was that live he
goes over these stories with you guys
and we're having a great time yesterday
we were laughing at uh
judge Weinbach over on Fox News she
forgot that she was vaccinated
so we were watching that clip and
but again I I do appreciate all the
support you give here uh on our show on
this show and on Gabe's show it means so
much to me it really does because you
guys keep us going here we're funded uh
from viewers like you there's no
corporate sponsor giving us money
there's no there's there's no secret
dark George Soros type check that we get
we don't get any of that it's only you
guys that support us so we appreciate
all the support that you give us not
just in in monetary value because that's
important that's really important it's
our job that's how we you know eat and
pay the bills and keep the lights on and
keep the microphone on
That's How We Do It
um so I appreciate all that support that
you give but being here every single day
listening engaging sharing the links
getting your friends to listen
um that's that's just as important if
not more important than than the money
that is sent and the monetary support
that is given uh to me and to Gabe and
we appreciate every single bit of it all
right you guys are lifeblood you guys
are what keeps us going in this fight
against Trump against the Republican
Nazis against the project 2025 because
man that's going to be a Battleground
that thing will live long past Trump the
project 2025. and the cat is out of the
bag
that's the craziest part think about it
for a second
their plan for a fascist theocracy
they've got it now in writing
and it's all the fascist think tanks
that put this [__] in writing they got
together and like you know what we
should do we should do what Nazi Germany
did in the 1930s but we should do it
here in America
I'm gonna lay it out for you over the
coming months
I'm gonna show you the I'm going to show
you the exact comparisons and where you
can go to find these things and be like
show show the [__] out there
that are still saying they're gonna vote
Republicans because of gas prices and
ceiling fans gas stoves and gay beer
show them why they're being tricked
into [__] into [__] culture wars
while the party that they vote for is
gonna take away their [__] Liberty
and take away their way of life because
that's their [__] plan Bet On It just
doubt me if you want to
I don't care
don't go you can doubt me but don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show and did you
know you can get your very own pardon
blanket go to image.com that's I am Gabe
sanchez.com
this is your very own pardon blanket at
his merch store pick one of those up
look over there and get you a nice handy
hard blanket you can give to your
Republican family members they might
need it who knows
need a pardon too who knows I mean a lot
of a lot of these [__]
insurrectionists could use a pardon if
they could have their family members
could have bought them a pardon blanket
you know what I mean
ah oh my God it's a great way to mock
them if not for anything else
I appreciate all the support again that
you guys give I want to show you the
Tony michaels.com one more time I know
they show this all the time but you
should subscribe up here at the top it
doesn't cost you anything what what
happens is I don't like sell your
information or anything I just send you
notifications in your email when you
subscribe so like when we have a new
show link I I do that or if any of the
links change or there's something new
coming up I I notify you in your email
so if you want to get emails on any
updates for the show just hit subscribe
up at the top of the Tony michaels.com
the one thing I do want to mention
um you know because we've gotten a lot
of people signing up so far uh to be to
be considered for moderators we do need
more moderators since we're doing more
uh content and longer longer content
here with Gabe and we're broadcasting on
different channels we are going to need
more mod sign signups so if you want to
be a moderator or be considered to be a
moderator for either our show and the
attorney Michael's podcast here or that
what was that live with Gabe Sanchez or
the pre-show just go ahead and sign up
at the mod sign up you just go to the
attorney michaels.com pan down it's the
mod sign up sheet there you just fill it
out
to the best year ability and we'll we're
going to get back to you uh we're we're
trying to figure out the best way to
have all the moderators on the same page
communicating and doing that so we
appreciate everyone who's already signed
up if you've signed up just be patient
we'll get to you
um and we'll let you know if you're on
consideration for the times and the
platforms that you put in for because
that's one thing on the sheet you'll
have you'll have like times that you can
do it uh in days that you can do it what
platforms you can do it on all that's on
the sheet so just go to the attorney
michaels.com pan down go to the my mod
sign up sheet if you want to sign up to
be considered to be a moderator which is
a high honor we have the best moderators
in the world
um so you better have your p's and q's
together
they're going to be pretty picky because
they are kind of picky but that's what
makes a great moderator right kind of
picky they investigate things you know
what I mean so we have the best
moderators here in the world and the
[__] fam universe
now also also if uh anyone out there
knows Discord uh and you want to be a
moderator they're looking for him on
Discord too
um not right away but we will be looking
for these in time the reason why I say
not right away on some of these things
it might take us a while to get back to
you and the reason why is because we
don't necessarily need a moderator right
now today but we're going to need them
in the future and the reason why is
because we got more hours we got more
people there's more audience members
joining the community there's more
people communicating in the Discord
um so don't forget to go to that Discord
the Link's in the chat or or you can go
to the Tony michaels.com and you can pan
down
all the way down and you can hit the
Discord server link right there on the
Tony michaels.com and find it there so
I hope I got that business out of the
way
I know uh the moderators will appreciate
having more and more names again we've
gotten several names already that have
signed up so if you've signed up don't
worry we've got your name we've got it
handy um we'll we'll be going through
them in the coming months and as we need
more and more moderators we'll be
getting in touch with you since you put
your name on the consideration list so
we appreciate everyone who has uh
volunteered their name to be considered
to be a moderator
appreciate it a lot all right let's get
to some [__] here because there's tons
of [__] to get to I want to get to this
Mitt Romney um this Mitt Romney stuff
but first of all I miss I've been
missing a clip so I don't want to I
don't want to miss it again
well let's see
[Music]
um
this is the the the
judge box wine clip but this one is from
several days ago
um
I forget his name but they're at a a
world economic forum and I can't believe
the [__] that's coming out of his mouth
um and it's supposed to be the financial
review profit summary his name is Tim uh
gennerman he's the he's the he's the
he's the founder and CEO I think he is
in this the same guy that said
I don't know he said something dumb here
recently but listen to this [__] I can't
believe this is what again
you're you're wanting you're wondering
what the wealth component of uh fascist
theocracy is because wealthy people they
don't they don't I am [__] they're
not faithful they don't really believe
they pretend to
right but this is what they want all
around the world watch this [__] let's
listen to this game listen to what he
says about workers listen what he says
about the economy what rich people want
for the economy listen
I think the problem that we've had is
that we've you know we we have
people decided they didn't really want
to work so much anymore through covert
and that has had a massive issue on
productivity you know tradies have
definitely pulled back on productivity
you know they they have been paid paid a
lot to do not too much in the last what
the are you [__] [__] me okay now
I I actually agree with him on this
point but his perspective of it is
[__] up here when you hear it oh it's
totally [__] backwards and it's
[__] up he doesn't give a [__] about
the worker he doesn't give a [__] about
people he doesn't give a [__] about
their labor he doesn't give a [__]
they are his slaves when you hear what
he says that is what the [__] that's
what they're saying now
I've told you this before and I've been
saying it for a long time that that
that's that's what kovid made us realize
as as a nation and really though all
around the world
that here's the thing
we don't owe corporations anything for
the job they give us okay we don't owe
them a [__] a special thank you or
some kind of [__] loyalty because
they don't have [__] love they don't
give a [__]
about the worker I mean here's this guy
like oh these [__] lazy bastards
they do they do work for no this
[__] sitting on gazillions of
dollars probably up his ass doing
nothing
making money off the the [__] labor
the profits off the labor of the people
[__] him [__] him hard [__] him
but I've been telling you this is the
he's right
normal average people were like yeah
we're [__] sick and tired of you
taking advantage of us you remember this
during the covet crisis a lot of people
sat at home and some people who didn't
make [__] the shittiest jobs you can get
out there in some of the lowest pay
those [__] were essential you
remember all this oh you're essential
you're essential to keeping our economy
and our country going but we ain't gonna
pay you like your essential
and you know what those people thought
well [__] you
[__] you if I'm essential I'm gonna go
be essential somewhere else [__]
not for the pay you're giving me
if I'm so goddamn essential then pretend
at least pretend like I'm essential
and that's that's a realization that
America came to is [__] you
number one money's not the most
important thing
the money's not the most important thing
freedom is way more important than money
because when you have freedom and
liberty to kind of move about
move jobs change
what you're doing for a living and a
career especially especially when maybe
there's companies out there that
appreciate you just a little more unlike
this [__] who has no
appreciation for workers whatsoever when
you hear what the [__] he says
listen to what he says listen to what he
says about the economy and what we
should do last few years and we need to
see that change we need to see
unemployment rise unemployment has to
jump 40 50 in my view
unemployment has to jump 40 50 in my
view
what the f he's like you know what
people we need to lose we the economy
needs to go in the [__] so that
people realize that the job they have is
a gift from us [__] you buddy [__] you
our labor is a gift to you and you owe
us money for our labor
most Americans most people in the world
the only [__] thing they have to
trade in the economy the only Capital
that they have to trade in the economy
is their [__] labor
okay most people don't have a bunch of
[__] money laying around you Silver
Spoon sons of [__]
dolls they have is their [__] labor
to trade that's it
that's the only Capital that they have
is their time
and you're like [__] you
you should be thanking us that we gave
you money
for your time get the [__] out of here
with that nonsense
not even close to what the reality of it
is
but he wants unemployment to rise
here you go let's keep listening it gets
oh it gets way better we need to say
painting the economy when they undermine
people that they work for the employer
not the other way around I mean oh oh is
that right is that right you sons of
[__] you you're gonna oh yep what we
need to do is we need to tank the
economy so the workers realize that
we're their masters
we're their masters it ain't the other
way around we they wouldn't survive
without us the the Masters the slave man
get the [__] out of here with this
slavery talk you piece of [__]
that is not what capitalism is
[__] that's not what it is
not even close to capitalism
this is plutocracy is what this [__]
is talking about that there's a certain
class of people that get to [__] that
get the control all the [__] money
they get to draw all the [__] money
all the [__] money
that's not capitalism that's plutocracy
that's oligarchy you dumb [__]
and again people p
people don't understand my stance on it
you know especially lefties
they're like oh how can you how can you
like capitalism I'm like this guy isn't
describing capitalism
this is not capitalism that he's
describing
a real true capitalist a real true
capitalist understands the price of
Labor and understands that the labor
that they buy that they purchase from
the workers because that's what they're
doing they're trading money for labor
the true capitalist
s who are good stewards of business good
real good which we have few and far
between anymore
most of these [__] are just
hyped up [__] in cells that somehow
had gotten a silver spoon in their mouth
true good Steward capitalist understand
that the money they trade for labor
the money they trade for labor is an
investment into their profits
and they cannot they cannot trade away
that investment for greed
they're few and far between anymore but
this guy is not describing capitalism
folks he's describing plutocracy he is
describing oligarchy he is saying there
is a certain class of people who own the
businesses and we get to tell you what
the [__] to do because you're our slaves
let's keep going there is a there's been
a systematic change where employees feel
the employer is extremely lucky to have
them they should feel [__] Mucky
exactly it that it's not it's not a
systematic change it's the truth [__]
it's the [__] truth why can't anyone
[__] come to this conclusion it's the
God damn truth
they we don't owe them a goddamn thing
not a [__] thing [__] them
they [__] owe us for our [__]
labor for our work that's the capital
that we give you you give us your
Capital money [__]
he's not describing [__] capitalism
at all
he's describing a [__] oligarchy and
a platocracy that's what he's describing
a monarchy almost
we owe you
we owe you get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense I don't know you a goddamn
thing
you can take your you can take your puny
little job and you can stick it straight
up your [__] ass that's what these
people should be telling these sons of
[__] and they are that's the whole
point that's what he's scared of he's
scared that the workers know the truth
they're terrified of the truth just like
Republicans are terrified of the [__]
truth
they're terrified of it so much so that
they'll make some kind of backwards ass
narrative that doesn't even make sense
when you [__] think about it
for two seconds just put your goddamn
brain cells that you got left and rub
them together and you come up with the
conclusion that oh
this guy's an [__]
it's a dynamic that has to challenge
we've got to kill that attitude and that
has to come through hurting the economy
which is what the whole Global you know
the the world is trying to do the
governments around the world are trying
to increase unemployment to get that
to some sort of normality and we're
seeing it I think every employer now is
seeing it I mean there is definitely
massive layoffs going off people might
not be talking about it but people are
definitely laying people off and we're
starting to see less arrogance in the
employment market and that has to
continue because that will Cascade
across the cost balance he's saying this
[__] out loud folks I don't know if you
know this he's saying this [__] out loud
he's saying this [__] out loud
and everyone thinks I'm hyperbolic oh my
God Tony you you just get way out of
hand with things
you get way out of hand I've been saying
for years since covid on this show this
the exact same thing that this guy's
bitching about
now I'm I'm saying it's a good thing
that employer employees in this country
have realized what the actual trade is
for years and years and years there's
been this attitude in this country
that we owe the people that we work for
some kind of [__] some kind of
[__] loyalty
are we owe them something [__] you you
owe me [__]
I trade my labor you give me money that
is how this system works
you either want capitalism or you don't
don't be selling this plutocracy [__]
and this idea that governments around
the world are trying are trying to make
sure that unemployment's low that is a
that is a crock of [__]
the oligarchy
the oligarchy the platocracy is trying
to get unemployment to be higher
that way they can wit their slaves into
shape
because that's what the [__] he's
talking about
it's what he's doing
[__] out of here with this nonsense
that that workers the only Capital
workers have
is their labor and they're not they're
not deserving and they they owe the the
person they're trading the labor to
that's what they owe them is the labor
they don't owe them anything else they
don't own loyalty or anything else they
owe them the labor that's it you pay me
and I'll give you my [__] work and
that's as far as it goes [__] and
that's how it should be and these
corporations should be put in their
place they should be scared at their
entire workforces will drop on them like
a drop of a hat and their profits will
be in danger [__] you
speaking of brainless idiots do you
remember uh
oh
I play it again I can't help but play it
here this is a quote this is a senator
yeah we're gonna listen to this again
yeah it's strap in or strap on whichever
eyes here is that zero days is it zero
days now is our counter down to zero
days uh strapping or strap on because
we're gonna listen to John Kennedy
regener queer here again and then I got
a great response to it oh my God it's a
fantastic response because Republicans
are like oh liberals were so offended by
John Kennedy saying this stuff in the
Senate I wasn't offended [__] I think
it's the funniest [__] on the internet
did you guys get the sense at all that I
was offended by what John Kennedy said I
thought it was hilarious
I honestly there's nothing better for me
uh to see John Kennedy be reading
genderqueer he should do it in every
[__] hearing that he is from now on
anytime there's a microphone in front of
John Kennedy the senator should [__]
regener queer he should just quote it
that should be his stump speech from now
here on Fourth
called genderqueer yeah okay okay let me
read an excerpt from that quote do it
yeah I got a new strap home strap-on
harness today you did
I can't wait to put it on you sounds
like you're excited it will fit my
favorite dildo perfectly oh man it looks
so hot
what a great time you'll have to have
your [__] in my mouth you can't oh my
God I won't give you the [__] of your
life oh I'm excited too now inside of me
end quote
oh man uh Senator John Kennedy wow
boy that
[Laughter]
why do people think that liberals would
be offended by that that is [__]
hilarious
to watch Senator John Kennedy
say that [__] that's hilarious come on
I don't think so I I think it's great I
think it's great I think it's hilarious
uh but here's a rebuttal a little bit of
a rebuttal and it was found on Tick Tock
here about you know books and banning
books and books that have pornography
and sexuality in them oh man we gotta
ban all those books every single last
one of them that have porn
and sexuality in them well maybe they
missed this book this is a great book
they should ban maybe they should
consider Banning this one that this this
lady here is talking about in a school
board meeting of course it occurs to me
that if you're worried about sex there's
another book that really needs to be on
your radar
it's a classic oh yeah it has loads of
explicit sexual content more than any of
the banned books that I read this summer
no [__] it starts off with a guy named
Adam and a woman named Eve frolicking
naked in public and not even being
ashamed that sounds familiar of rum
pretends that his hot wife is his sister
what twice lending her to pharaoh and
Avi Melech in order to save his own life
Sarah encourages her husband to sleep
with their Nanny God lot offers his
virgin daughters to an angry mob of sex
offenders Leia and Rachel who are
sisters marry the same guy and then they
fight for the next several years over
who's gonna sleep with him each night
Jacob impregnates both of them and then
has sex with their handmaids as well
seems kind of salacious dresses up as a
prostitute and has sex with her
father-in-law and Potiphar's wife tries
to seduce Joseph and then accuses him of
attempted rape and that's just in the
Book of Genesis just wait until you see
what happens with King David
[Applause]
whoa whoa wait a second what is this
book that she so speak of what is this
book that she so speak of huh it seems
like it seems like uh
book that devland's pornography
it definitely seems like it has uh sex
and sexuality in it I wonder I wonder
what that book could be
ah these [__] idiots
these [__] idiots
again another rake step you know a lot
of people figure that don't know how to
[__] combat this stuff it's exactly
this here it's exactly this here
yes it's the [__] Bible go ban the
Bible then you pieces of trash if you're
gonna ban if you're gonna ban a book
that John Kennedy's reading in the
Senate about adolescents becoming adults
when they're in the lgbtq community
and it's designed for those specific
folks
that book genderqueer
which it's won a ton of awards which I
can now see why that book gender queer
is won so many awards I mean when you
have someone like John Kennedy
performing and quoting from it it's
beautiful isn't it I mean it it's the
best piece of art on the internet today
way better than the Bible was even way
back when
so get your [__] head straight if
you're so worried about books that
promote sexuality and promote and
promote sex and salacious and
pornography get the [__] over it you're
gonna have to ban the Bible too okay
you're gonna have to do it that's just
something you're gonna have to do so if
you don't like the words ban the Bible
then shut the [__] up and move on all
right
it's enough in the nonsense it's enough
of the [__] okay we don't want to
hear your [__] capitulating to
Fascism to these [__] with
casseroles these it's this [__]
Taliban and minivans this moms of
Liberty these these [__] women who
who love Hitler they do they [__]
love Hitler they quote them in their
[__] newsletters give me a [__]
break ban the Bible if you're gonna ban
genderqueer okay okay
Kennedy
pieces of trash great rebuttal them
again oh you know what you know what and
I I played so many videos to try to
rebut these people
you know it's like a through line with
these videos the thing that they all
kind of have in common
it's always women
it's always women bringing the best
arguments to the Ford lunch you don't
know said you ever notice that it's
almost like women are way better than
men at anything really good God
governing [__] top of the list
but just thinking critically
is more important
speaking to someone who gives a perfect
analysis of something this is kind of
backwards here though
everyone everyone's wanting to talk
about this Lauren bobert
uh Beetlejuice thing right oh my God
listen
the problem with this Lauren Boer
Beetlejuice thing is it's not really not
that big of a story folks it's not it
really isn't
it it isn't
and and really when you're when you're
when you're knocking her for being
kicked out for acting a fool because I
mean to be honest she was probably drunk
or High I mean that's what it seems like
in the report because they weren't
causing much of a disturbance till after
intermission so my guess is they wanted
they went and got [__] doped up or or
whatever the hell was in her Vape him
maybe she had THC in her vape pen I
don't know that would be my guess that's
why they're being loud obnoxious and
then they were breaking the rules in the
theater right I mean you know you break
the rules in the theater every once in a
while you've done it I've done it right
maybe not to the extent that it's a big
huge [__] show of Beetlejuice in
Denver
and there's hundreds of people in the
audience and she's [__] disturbing
them here's the thing here's the thing
if you got kicked out if you got kicked
out of the [__] theater you'd
probably [__] throw up the finger to
someone who's kicking you out especially
if you're drunk or stoned right it's
gonna happen but here's the thing here's
the thing the problem is the hypocrisy
right it's it's the hypocrisy it's not
really that you know she [__] broke
the law or she's some kind of criminal
because she was vaping and recording in
a theater she was breaking the rules and
they kicked her out for breaking the
rules okay
it's the hypocrisy
it's the hypocrisy that matters here
because she's the one preaching to us
about how the [__] we're supposed to be
right
you know she actually gets up on stage
and she's strutting around like a
[__] rooster talking about God and
God this God that you should love God
and you Jesus this Jesus that I'm gonna
tell you how to be and how to act and
who to marry who the [__] what clothes
to wear what books to read now [__] you
[__] [__] you
yeah you ain't gonna tell me [__]
especially when your dumb ass is doing
what you did in the Beetlejuice theater
okay
I'm not going to listen to you where the
[__]
and it's kind of offensive when the left
kind of comes at bobert in a certain way
I'm gonna let trait I'm gonna let Trey
Crowder and talk about it here the
liberal redneck he actually breaks it
down this is one this is the uh out of
all of them and really I could I
couldn't do it any better than myself
myself so I'm just gonna let him do it
I've played several of his videos before
because he has such a good breakdown of
some of these things but listen to Trey
here and really honestly take it
seriously because I know he's joking
here and he makes a lot of funny jokes
and it's hilarious but he's being
serious here about this stupid situation
with the [__] bobert and Beetlejuice
watch
y'all every time I hear something else
about Lauren bobert I become more
convinced that we somehow went to high
school together or something you know I
know this person man I do because see
I'm up the Whiskey Tango persuasion
myself and as such I know another trash
monster when I see one okay I mean you
know it's not like she tries to hide it
or anything she just got kicked out of
the theater in Denver for vaping and
hollering stuff right my fellow trailer
Americans I ask you who Among Us okay
but no seriously bobert checks so many
red ass boxes it's insane and like she
was born in Florida aka the Fertile
Crescent of crazy crackers right to a
teen mom natch she grew up on welfare
and food stamps she dropped out of high
school when she herself got knocked up
now that baby's having a baby so she's a
36 year old mammal she married then
divorced a guy I couldn't stop pulling
his dick out in public she's always
talking [__] about having a gun in her
purse and she has an ongoing feud with
the other craziest [__] in town some
top shelf trashery right there it is
like you just know she claims her
grandma is one quarter Cherokee right
and I'm saying all that makes me kind of
wish that I could root for this person
you know honestly like I do like if she
was out here actually standing up for
the little guy and taking the elites
down a peg Reed and stuff knowing facts
[__] like that I'd be all for it I'd be
like hell yeah finally some
representation you know but she's not no
she's dedicated her life to being wrong
out loud you know like she every time
she talks it's like the chat GPT for
harmful ignorance like she outwardly
hates other marginalized groups she
screws over our own people by trying to
take away the exact same government
benefit programs that kept her alive as
a child like loud I cannot stand a
ladder puller y'all drives me crazy I'm
saying I don't hate Lauren bobert
because she's white trash I hate her
because she's a piece of [__] right I
know some of y'all are going to hear
that and think well that's redundant but
it's not it's really not
some of the kindest most genuine and
empathetic people I've ever known were
trailer babies and an affinity from
Mountain Dew and the early works of Limp
Bizkit did not change that fact okay
this country would do well to have a
chamber full of them but alas it is not
to be no instead we've got bobert and
bobert is just another loudmouth
vindictive [__] who somehow took away
all the wrong lessons from her life and
now spends her time spewing misplaced
rage and making us all look bad it's a
damn shame love y'all uh I couldn't have
said it better than what Trey said it
right there
look look her worst trait is not that he
what he called her a trash monster
that's not her worst trait
that's not her worst trait that she's
some kind of [__]
trailer baby as he said
that's not our worst [__] trait
there's plenty of us out there no way
I'm not [__] perfect you know that
[__]
I got all kinds of [__] running around
on me I mean God damn I like to I like
to [__] drink Jaeger I like to get
high every once in a while I I
I I I love talking about porn
and I'm I'm I'm not from the the most
highfalutin place in the [__] world
the Lake of the Ozarks in Missouri
that's not the most highfaluted place in
the world the highfalutin [__]
from Kansas City and St Louis like to
think it's theirs but it's not
let's stop kidding ourselves we're not
we're not we're we're not we're not any
better and that's the thing that's
that's why I think trade connects with
people
on this level
is because he's not trying to hide
who he really is behind some kind of
elitism Liberals are really [__] bad
at that right they want to be the
elitist so they try to pretend that
people below them [__] that [__] because
again Lauren Bowers worst trait isn't
that she's a piece of white trash it's a
she's a piece of [__] like he said
trying to [__] pull the ladder up on
people when the only reason why she is
where she is is because of the social
safety net in this country
the social safety net allowed Lauren
Boer to come a [__] member of
Congress
and she just she's just gonna [__]
just dump all over the rest of the
people who are like her
who grew up like her in areas like her
that are trash monsters as Trey says
which I love that trash monster
our trailer baby
you know there's a lot of trailer babies
out there that weren't even raised in
trailers
and it seems derogatory but go talk to
someone who grew up in a [__] trailer
park talk to him
he's right
they'd [__] give you the shirt off
their [__] back a lot of them and
they ain't hardly got a shirt to give
you
because they know how hard it is to
suffer they know what it is like to
suffer
and Lauren bobert's gonna turn around
when she gets power and [__] all over
those people well [__] her [__] that
[__]
not gonna happen here not now and that's
that's the point of the stupid [__]
story that everyone want to make a big
deal that she was vaping and hollering
in a goddamn theater who gives a [__]
who gives a [__] it's about her [__]
on people like herself how she grew up
how she made it in this country [__]
on them trying to take away the social
safety net [__] her
[__] her thank you Trey
and for the perfect the perfect analysis
of the bobert Beetlejuice Saga the
Scandal
yeah I know a lot of people are mad at
me because I'm pointing out the fact
that people were trying to make it it's
not a scandal it's not a scandal she's
it this is bobert what are you talking
about
[__] a lot of us would go to a theater
and holler and like to vape and get high
I'm not gonna lie to you I've I've got
an affinity it's a it's a it's a
tradition now I get stoned before I go
to the movie I want to be stoned to go
to the theater I'm not gonna lie
the popcorn tastes better the candy
tastes better the movie lasts longer the
chairs are more comfortable
for me
I mean I'm not yelling and screaming in
a movie and recording it
but yeah I'm not saying that it wouldn't
happen if I got stoned enough
but it's the hypocrisy of it all
she's a piece of [__]
the thing just what Trey said she's a
piece of [__] all right let's get to
this up you know actually
let's go back one because Lauren bobert
loves the Bible and we talked about uh
John Kennedy uh you know reading the
genderqueer out loud he loves that book
it's his favorite book ever in the
history of ever and then you know we had
the Bible come in of how sexual it is
how much of a book of grooming it is
well let's go um speaking of the Bible
let's see the good liars here they were
interviewing a woman she's talking about
the Bible of course because it has to do
with the issue of abortion so they
always invoke the Bible let's listen
here to this clip uh what she thinks
about the Bible and being pro lying from
Pro baby let's listen we need to abolish
abortion no exceptions so this says
before I formed you in the womb I knew
you and that that's from the Bible yeah
from Jeremiah one right so God knows
these babies in the womb he has a
purpose and a Destiny for each child
they shouldn't be killed oh wow you know
period She you know she she's apparently
formed an opinion from the book
apparently the book that she's been
reading she formed an opinion from the
problem is is she probably missed parts
of it let's see didn't he kill all the
firstborn sons in Egypt
I think I'm done
I think I'm done yeah you are done you
are done
you are [__] done
so this is dead as dumb as dog [__] that
these people spout this [__] from the
Bible from this book that should be
banned by their standards I'm just
saying ban the Bible we should ban the
[__] Bible folks and we should burn
them all if we hey if we got a ban and
burn genderqueer we gotta burn and ban
the Bible That's Just fact of the matter
these fascists are going to ban
genderqueer we gotta we gotta ban the
Bible hashtag ban the Bible
but they don't even know what the [__]
is in this book
this dumb ass picks out one [__]
piece of the book puts it on a sign and
thinks she's not going to be challenged
come on that's the point if you have an
opinion about something and I'm sure
this lady has all kinds of opinions
about all kinds of things right oh my
God I'm sure she just got all kinds of
[__] opinions and she's got all kinds
of Bible verses that she's Cherry Picked
to back up her opinions
but if you have an opinion on something
and you have a [__] belief on
something then [__] defend it would
you would you please [__] defend it
I'll defend my opinions I'll defend my
beliefs and and it's pretty easy because
they're they're mainly mostly 99 are
based in fact you know that's where I
develop my opinions from that's why a
lot of you don't like some of the things
I say even though you're here and you're
liberal is because I tell you [__]
that's all I tell you things that are
[__] that people are telling you
that aren't real and I say that it's all
[__] like the 14th Amendment thing I
know some people are still mad at me and
you'll continue to be mad because I'm
gonna keep bringing it up and the reason
why is because when it fails I'm going
to point it out that I was I was right
it's all [__] all that shit's
[__] they're just they're [__]
they're feeding you full of a bunch of
horse [__]
is that is that how it's gonna happen
okay
it could happen that way yeah and Mike
Pence could have crowned Donald Trump
King too they thought that too okay so
easy easy on the whole it could happen
all right
but if you got an opinion and you got a
[__] belief defend it [__] defend
it you pile of [__]
this lady's like and she glitched you
know like oh God
I didn't I didn't even read that part of
the Bible and didn't even think about it
that way oh man
I thought it was an infallible book that
I was gaining my opinions from all this
[__] in here was facts
and when you point out something in the
book where she thinks it's infallible
and it [__] breaks down her argument
in a matter of a second
she can't defend it she I I'm done here
I'm walking away
because she's not grounded in facts
right if she was actually genuine about
her beliefs or her opinion because
that's the other thing and I'll say it
again if I don't say it a million times
there is a difference between an opinion
and your belief your belief can be in an
opinion
it can be your belief
can be an opinion but an opinion is
based in fact okay you gotta agree on a
certain set of facts before you develop
an opinion A belief you don't have to
have any [__] facts none of them
you're not that facts you just make that
[__] up
if you want to be quite honest
what do you need what do you need facts
for if you have a belief yeah you just
gotta look deep down inside yeah
and really figure out what you want to
[__] some other people
so this lady is a prime example
prime example
of of fascist in this country who want
to take away Women's Health Care with no
exception we want to make sure women ban
Women's Health Care with no exception
not even the life of the woman
what about the name because she's like
oh you had a name before you were born
what about the name of a woman who's
gonna die because you got religious
beliefs that you hold dear that are
based in no fact and they're not an
opinion they're just a [__] belief so
that woman's got to die because you
believe some book some [__] book
that needs to be banned by your
standards
come on man
[__] out of here with this nonsense ban
the Bible hashtag ban the Bible there
you go
[__] them that's a that's a hell of a
campaign isn't it uh thank you for the
good layers of being out there and just
challenging these people because that's
what you have to do you just have to
challenge them just ask them a question
just challenge them just a little bit
you know I've got to do it a lot I mean
he didn't like stand there and do some
kind of monologue
it was just one sentence one question
[Laughter]
tore apart her entire life didn't it you
know this that [__] [__] walks around
all the time talking to her friends at
card games and [__] telling people at
the grocery store all kinds of [__]
about abortion in the Bible she's the
one standing in the grocery line trying
to convert you to Christianity in her
way of thinking don't you know it
full-on [__] Karen for sure 100
percent full stop she is
and she can't she can't take one
challenge one sentence one question get
the [__] out of here
come on man let's get to the Mitt Romney
all right Steph and Gabe Sanchez I think
he's probably gonna be uh joining us
here in a little bit he gave Santa's
gonna jump in on the show I believe
before he goes to um his hour that's
right Gabe Sanchez has a full hour
now you're going to want to stay tuned
here on YouTube and twitch if you're
watching from the main channel here on
YouTube or twitch you're going to want
to stay tuned here
because it's going to jump directly to
Gabe's show
you're not going to miss a beat it's
going to go directly in there to what
was that live where Gabe has a full hour
live hour now on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays right after the Tony Michaels
podcast that's how we're delivering
three hours a day you guys have been
calling for three hours a day for a long
time and he he had so many stories that
he had to get to with what was that and
what was that is becoming more and more
successful
um and his channel has gotten more and
more attention with the what was that
he's grown almost ten thousand if he's
not over it right now
uh subscribers on his YouTube channel if
you're not a subscriber to Gabe's
Channel go there right now just if
you're on YouTube I am Gabe Sanchez a
search bar at the top I am Gabe Sanchez
and you'll take you right there to his
page subscribe to his page and support
Gabe in that effort if you're on
Facebook I I apologize Gabe doesn't do
Facebook so
I do sort of
um I broadcast there because I think
it's important to get the word out to as
many people as we possibly can on these
pages so Facebook is one of them
reluctantly but go support Gabe on
YouTube and on Twitch and you can find
him on Twitch too just if you go to
Twitch if you're on Twitch sound just
search I am Gabe Sanchez you can always
just search him anywhere I am Gabe
Sanchez or you can go to
iamgabysanches.com you'll find all his
links there that takes you directly to
his link tree so you can find all this
stuff and go get your pardon blanket go
get some some merch yeah you can you can
go uh follow him on YouTube or on Twitch
and and take a look at what was that
live it's going to be an up and coming
show I know it is with the live show and
his well-produced what was that uh and
also follow him on patreon and give him
some support on patreon and you can
actually be a YouTube member his channel
is monetized so you guys can go uh help
support Gabe on his YouTube channel
because it is monetized so I appreciate
it so much that you guys support him you
support me and his show is going to be
growing just just because of you guys
the audience uh support him so thank you
very much for supporting me so stay
tuned after this show we're gonna get to
that all right let's get to the Mitt
Romney [__]
and let me let me play his uh his
statement first he put out a statement
and that he's not he's not gonna he's
not gonna seek reelection
you know
this [__] guy he's deciding that he
can't he's gonna be primary and ain't
gonna work uh and because he's going to
be primaried
then he can't seek reelection because it
would be a total [__] embarrassment
if Mitt Romney ran for United States
Senate was primary it would destroy his
legacy as he sees it that's why he's not
running it has nothing to do with his
morals or that he thinks that the
Republican party is abandoned the
Constitution ain't got [__] to do with
that
yeah I don't give me that shipment don't
give me that [__] mitt
I know what it's about it's about your
own [__] ego is what this is about
um I mean God damn his statement surely
it's here somewhere people let's go to
people here I know it's on his his uh
his main account here it is here's his
statement
that he released yesterday it's about
three minutes long we'll take a look at
it here's Mitt Romney capitulating to
both sides the both sides argument that
[__] you know contrary to a lot of
expectations I enjoy my work in the
Senate a good deal
the last few years have been
particularly productive as I was able to
help lead and negotiate the bipartisan
infrastructure law
a comprehensive China strategy process
religious liberty protections a
compromised gun safety law the Electoral
account act reform and emergency coveted
relief funding
I was also able to help secure key Utah
priorities including funding for Hill
Air Force Base and its program to
modernize our nuclear deterrent as well
as funding for Wildfire prevention water
infrastructure rural Broadband removal
of uranium tailings from Moab expansion
and restoration of our Highway and
Transit infrastructure and federal
studies to save the Great Salt Lake
I've spent my last 25 years in public
service of one kind or another
at the end of another term I'd be in my
mid-80s
frankly it's time for a new generation
of leaders
they're the ones that need to make the
decisions that will shape the world they
will be living in
now we Face critical challenges mounting
national debt climate change and the
ambitious authoritarians of Russia and
China what about the authoritarians here
mitt how about those you know the the
domestic terrorists that we have I mean
you know it's Russia might be a threat
China might be there what about the ones
here huh
here comes the both sides of [__]
neither President Biden nor former
president Trump are leading their party
to confront those issues
on deficits and debt both men refuse to
address entitlements even though they
know that this represents two-thirds of
federal spending oh Mitt Romney still
wants to still wants to take your Social
Security and your Medicare away from you
your entitlements you know you know your
entitlements you know like that guy that
we watched earlier who are like look
[__] we make you you work for us
you're our slaves you're not entitled to
anything you piece of [__] we're
entitled to your labor you're not
entitled to our money when you give us
your labor this is this is Mitt Romney's
thinking Mitt Romney thinks the same
thing that that [__] thinks same
[__] [__] same [__] [__] he thinks
he's [__] in a higher class it's
oligarchy it's [__] plutocracy for
Mitt Romney that's his [__] that's
where his brain is at that's why he says
this [__] about Medicare and Social
Security as if their entitlements
entitlements my ass
how many of you [__] out there
that'll listen to me right now have a
paycheck on a W-2 and you get Medicare
and Social Security taken out of that
[__] check every goddamn week how
many of you I guarantee it's every
[__] one of you and it was your
entire [__] life
if you're still working it's still
you're it's still going on entitlement
my ass
we put our work and our money into
Social Security [__] in a Medicare
[__]
don't tell me about no [__]
entitlements ain't no entitlement
it's ours
we [__] paid for it
we earned it it is earned benefits not
entitlements Mitt Romney it's more of
that [__] [__] narrative that
that [__] earlier was saying about
how we owe Corporate America and we owe
the rich people we owe the oligarchs
all of all of our success [__] you [__]
you Mitt Romney
Donald Trump calls global warming a hoax
and President Biden offers feel-good
solutions that make no difference to the
global climate okay so Mitt Romney
claims that climate change is a really
big issue but but someone someone who
actually believes in it oh man that's
just not enough for Mitt Romney it's
just not enough I mean Joe Biden didn't
do enough to kill the social safety net
in this country so [__] that he ain't
good enough on climate change either get
the [__] out of here again a lot of
people yesterday like oh Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney [__] him [__] him Buckle his
Cheney [__] Adam King singer [__] Chris
Christie I'm telling you folks [__] them
this this thinking that Mitt Romney has
has led to Trump
this thinking that Mitt Romney has led
to the disease of fascism in this
country
it didn't just [__] [__] out of
nowhere
this [__] trickle-down [__] [__]
that they own you they own your labor
that they're the job creators they're
better than you [__] you [__]
[__] you this attitude is what has bread
fascism is bred the disease of trumpism
and Maga in this country this narrative
that Mitt Romney's saying this video
saying why he can't rerun because his
party didn't believe in the Constitution
your party hasn't believed in the
[__] constitution in a [__]
hundred years you pile trash
[__] Mitt Romney [__] him
on China President Biden under invest in
the military and president Trump under
invests in our alliances
both sides Bush she often impede the
solutions that these challenges demand
the next generation of leaders must take
America to the next stage of Global
Leadership yeah and get rid of dumbasses
like you
and dumbass narratives like your
narrative that you've been trying to
[__] trying to puke up on us for 40
[__] years Mitt Romney when you were
[__] when you were raping other
businesses with your [__] Venture
capitalism your [__] vulture
capitalism you piece of [__] you piece
of trash destroying parts of the economy
destroying businesses that provided jobs
for people that you claim are so good
[__] out of here with this [__] man
again a lot of people yesterday thought
all Mitt Romney's greatest ever oh it's
great to hear Mitt Romney say that the
Republicans don't believe in the
Constitution no [__] [__] Sherlock
it's a it's oh it's [__] news that
Mitt Romney came around to the
realization that the Republican Party
hates the Constitution that's [__]
news
[__] out of here
come on man let's get real here
let's get [__] real here Mitt Romney
is the reason why trumpism exists do you
[__] remember do you remember Mitt
Romney at the goddamn Republican
National Convention when he was
nominated for their [__] run their
their nominee for president in 2012. do
you remember that [__] whole thing
was a goddamn lie
the whole [__] thing was a goddamn
lie
I built that remember that I built that
it's not like Mitt Romney's some silver
spoon [__] it's not like Mitt
Romney's dad was the [__] governor
and it ran for [__] president for
crying out loud oh nope nope that's a
fact it happened Mitt Romney's a silver
spoon little [__] okay
Mitt Romney didn't come he ain't no
trailer baby
like [__] Trey Crowder said he ain't
no [__] trash monster he's part of
the oligarchy okay
thank you
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense of Mitt Romney some kind of
hero of our democracy he ain't he wasn't
gonna be he created the problem
it was his entire [__] the entirety
of his nomination at the Republican
National Convention in 2012 was all a
[__] lie
because Obama said if you got roads and
bridges businesses didn't build those
roads and bridges we built those roads
and bridges [__] we did you didn't
build that we built that the government
[__] built that us
we put that [__] together we did the
hard work of compromising we did the
hard work of of of [__] making sure
to have the right goddamn policies
to have to have roads and bridges and
[__] communication and internet
so that you you [__] could suck you
[__] could suck profit out of the
American people we built that
infrastructure you you didn't build that
and they [__] lied and said Obama
told businesses that they didn't build
their businesses well [__] you
well [__] you go to hell
and Mitt Romney's gonna sit here and
tell us lecture us on about about
[__] Biden or Trump
lying not having good policies
and trying to drop truth on us get the
[__] yeah [__] you and if you like Mitt
Romney for this statement you're not
looking at it correctly I'm sorry you're
just not seeing clearly enough what you
need to see
is that Mitt Romney was part of the
[__] problem with Trump hell [__]
Trump he [__] begged Trump to [__]
endorse him in 2012 and then Mitt Romney
stood on the [__] stage with the big
words I I built that
a big [__] lie the whole thing was a
lie
[__] you
get the [__] out of here
well I'm not running for re-election
yeah I'm not good hiring good bye
Felicia Bye Felicia United States
Senator until January
Shane that's a goddamn [__]
now and I'll Advance our state's
numerous priorities
I look forward to working with you and
with folks across our state and nation
in that endeavor
it really is a profound honor to serve
Utah and I'm sure it is and I thank you
for giving me the opportunity to do so
oh I'm sure it's just a great honor for
you to rape and pillage
businesses with vulture capitalism Mitt
Romney I'm sure it is oh man just the
highest [__] honor yeah
behind [__] honor [__] out of here
with this bull sizesm [__]
and the wise oh my God the [__] lies
man
the lies as if he thinks we won't know
the truth
as if he thinks we won't know the truth
we know the [__] truth you know the
truth I know the truth he can't hide
that [__] from us
it's all right there on tape it's all
you got to do
remember when he
when he was demeaning people you
remember that
that's one thing
you know
what an ass head
well here he is on CNN after he gave
this he did a little press gaggle
oh boy and he really says stuff that we
don't already know hmm I really said
stuff we don't already know oh okay go
ahead Mitt Romney tell us [__] we
already know let's hear it and to add to
that you had said just that a lot of the
party simply does not believe in the
Constitution what do you mean by that
well the the there were I was in a rally
where someone said to me you know if
you're elected this is what I was
running for Senate last time if uh if
you're elected will you close down ABC
NBC and CBS because they're not setting
out the truth and this was in a
republican rally and I was like really
they're no question there's no question
there's some portion of my party and the
opposition party who thinks we need to
have a a strong person a strong man to
put aside the Constitution for that
matter president Trump former president
Trump said we should put aside the
Constitution to reinstall him as
president I mean so yeah there are some
people who believe that I believe there
some people in your party are you
[__] me only some
what
how many don't believe that the
constitution is standing in their way
huh
you can count on your two [__] hands
the amount of Republicans that run
around pretending that they love the
Constitution and I say pretending for a
reason because they are [__]
pretending
Mitt Romney does not like the
Constitution I don't give a [__] how you
spend it what you say I don't give a
[__] and I don't care how many Mitt
Romney Defenders are out there AI isn't
going to be one because he doesn't give
a [__] about the Constitution
he wants what that other guy was saying
oligarchy that's what they want they
want oligarchy they want different
classes and different classes get
different rights
okay they want oligarchy
they don't want democracy and they
[__] hate the Constitution because of
it [__] if they had their way they'd go
all the way back and be originalist you
know to wear only white Property Owners
would have a vote
that's it
that's I mean they love that part of the
Constitution like way back when you know
before we got to
it being an actual democracy
he loves that part of the Constitution
the history of it he'd love to go back
then when only rich white property
powerful men have the right to vote oh
then they could really set us straight
right they could really show us and we
should appreciate them
because they're the power holders get
the [__] out of here with this [__]
Mitt Romney [__] him
and that's the way you should [__]
feel [__] him [__] Mitt Romney [__] him
[__] Liz Cheney [__] Chris Christie [__]
Adam kinsinger are you still Republican
oh you're oh you're still a member of
the Republican party oh you still think
that Republican party isn't is a viable
party well then [__] you
again what Mitt Romney should have said
clearly yesterday is that the Republican
party is dead
it is dead we are dragging around a dead
body all over the country and if we
don't get our [__] together
and get a second party that believes in
democracy our democracy is in Peril here
so I'm not a member of the Republican
party and I shouldn't have I should have
resigned at the Republican Party years
ago
years ago the Republicans
walked away from democracy walked away
from Liberty
that's what Memories should be saying
but he's not he's like oh Joe badden
just as bad as Trump
as if there's even a comparison of
someone who actually believes in the
foundation of our country Belize in the
foundation of the Constitution
okay
and Trump who wants project 2025.
the next fascist nazi Germany 1930
solution to our country [__] out of here
and comparing comparing someone who
believes in democracy
to someone like Trump acting as if
they're the same [__] you
I don't need that kind of [__]
especially when you genuflected to that
son of a [__] because you wanted the
nomination because you s you were
seeking power in 2012 based on lies lies
my friend
Mitt Romney kiss my ass
and anyone who defends him kiss my ass
oh my God here you go here you go you
want to defend me you want to defend
Mitt Romney here here's a great picture
I'll let you defend this mitt what's
this meant what is this
what's this whoa who is that it's
sitting there were you kissing his ring
because you wanted to be his secretary
of state is that what you're doing were
you going up there and kissing his ass
after he won huh how did you feel then
about democracy Mitt Romney how do you
feel about the Constitution then mitt
ROM did you ask this guy did you ask
this guy how he felt about the
Constitution when you went to kiss his
[__] ass try to be his secretary of
state or whatever the [__] you were
trying to be [__] out of here man
they're all [__] frauds man every one
of them
it's not realizing that Republicans
don't like the Constitution
hey Romney you don't like the
Constitution dummy
remember the 43 oh well there's 43
percent of the country
they were going to vote against me
because because they're Poor's them
Poors out there aren't going to vote
against me
okay
anyone defending Mitt Romney on the
internet yesterday today or from here on
Fourth
you're defending the wrong sumb [__]
you're defending the wrong some [__]
we're gonna have I think Gabe Sanchez
let me check let me check and see if the
guy with the last name Sanchez I think I
have time for one more clip before he
comes on it's possible
um you coming on today I'm just
messaging him
what's that that's how we do
I want to show you one more clip uh why
we're waiting on Gabe's inches this is
at the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill
you know I think it was last week
well actually it's like every week at
these universities they have lockdowns
because you know you know
there's a there's a [__] shooting
because Republican policies like Mitt
Romney but Republicans like Mitt Romney
capitulate to the NRA
you know they capitulate to the NRA the
federal Society they get they get judges
to block you know Common Sense gun
reform hey you like politicians
to make sure that the NRA runs rough
shot all over all over State legislation
and federal legislation make sure that
weapons of war get in the hands of
people who don't need weapons of war
um and they terrorize they terrorize
communities and particularly the
community at Chapel Hill the University
of North Carolina
apparently um yesterday there was
another [__] lockdown
at the UNC Chapel Hill uh University of
North Carolina
and the students were locked in rooms
again again it's their [__] life now
right
with the Republicans running around the
country right and the Republicans making
sure that anyone can get any kind of
guns anywhere anytime they don't have to
pay for it I mean the kid in Uvalde that
went and murdered little bitty children
where the cops wouldn't go in and save
them that's right I said it he didn't
have to pay for the guns he just went in
with a little piece of plastic he gave
the the gun store piece of plastic they
gave him all kinds of guns and ammo to
go [__] murder little kids and this
is what Republicans want
this is what they want they want they
want someone to be able to go into a gun
store with a little [__] piece of
plastic and they give them the piece of
plastic they hand them the guns and the
ammo right then they don't want no
background check no not no background no
ID no nothing they just want to be able
to get the guns in the hands so they can
go murder children down the street in
elementary school or at a college like
UNC Chapel Hill
what do you want from me
I'll tell you
and I'll tell you that's what they want
you think I'm lying well I mean don't
don't take it from me
don't take it from me don't don't don't
say oh Tony you're just making [__] up
huh don't take it for me
maybe maybe the students that were
locked down there Chapel Hill maybe that
would maybe that would
get you to pay attention let's listen
we
two weeks ago a gun was brought to our
campus
and yesterday a group of UNC students
from March for our lives were kicked out
of the state legislator for demanding
that our politicians do literally
[__] anything about this
Tim Moore Republican Speaker of the
House of Representatives mocked us and
laughed at us as we left
and today we are in our second lockdown
for the second shooting of our school
semester
I am done
students are terrified of going to our
schools
the one place that should be our
Sanctuary is our health
I am pissed I am angry and I demand
change
legislatures
do [__] anything about this this is
hell
so there you go
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you this again
with the sound off you can see all the
students here sitting in this this room
where they're locked down they can't go
anywhere because Republicans want want
to make sure that mass murderers get
weapons of war
that's what they want
that's what the [__] they want and when
these students go to talk to their
[__] politicians their elected
leaders they [__] laugh at them and
mock them
for being terrified
do you know one reason do you know run
reason let's back up a second do you
know one reason why Mitt Romney is
[__] resigning one of the reasons his
family isn't safe
from [__] domestic terrorists
he's scared of getting killed
murdered by domestic terrorists manga
supporters Trump supporters he's
terrified of it they I guess he pays
like five thousand dollars a [__]
month just for security
so that they don't get killed by a bunch
of [__] domestic terrorists Trump
supporters
he ain't gonna do [__] he won't say [__]
about these students here
oh yeah he'll pay five thousand dollars
a month he'll resign his seat and send
it because he's terrified terrified
someone's gonna mow him down and kill
him but these students I'm [__] [__]
them you know you know what you know
what because here's the thing Mitt
Romney probably believes that these are
just lowly workers these are just lowly
workers that should be loyal to the
oligarchy
the oligarchy are the ones that should
be terrified of terrorists you shouldn't
be terrified of terrorist if you're
dodging a few bullets and you got a
decent job with like the shittiest pay
ever because you went to college and
they did what they told you to do which
was go to college get a good job go get
a career uh hopefully it's not at a bank
where someone will come in and shoot you
up with an automatic rifle
[__] out of here man
[__] out of here
what are we doing huh what the [__] are
we doing
when we capitulate to this [__]
this kid this kid in this video he ain't
he don't give a [__]
and frankly more [__] college
students are more [__] college
campuses in this country and elementary
schools and school grounds churches
grocery stores every [__] one of them
should have a [__] attitude about
this and guns
and I'm telling you I'm telling you
folks the good news is is that if we can
fend off fascism
we could fend it off and get it to crawl
back underneath this rock
this [__] New Generation gen Z this
new generation and and gin Alpha coming
up behind them
they understand what [__]
authoritarian looks like
they [__] get it
they're locked down in classrooms
because the the government the fascist
government's just going to give anybody
a [__] gun give anybody a gun a
weapon of War to mow them down and kill
them
if they so wish
we have the right to bear arms in this
country
but we have the right also to be safe
the pursuit of happiness
and being locked down at a school over
and over and over I don't know if you
understand these kids how much they've
this is part of their [__] lives
it was not part of my life
I went to school in the 90s
I went to school in the 90s you know
what we did drills for we did drills for
tornadoes
our fire fire drills and tornado drills
we were terrified of firing tornadoes oh
my God those things are awful they'll
[__] kill you fire and tornadoes
they're a [__]
these kids not only do [__] do Mass
shooter drills
they have to be locked down because of a
mass shooter
this is like this is like if a kid lived
in a town in a school and they had to do
not tornado drills they had to be locked
down because of tornadoes twice a
[__] week
imagine tornadoes coming into towns and
mass murdering people twice a week
imagine that
I I would almost bet I would almost bet
that we would [__] do something about
it
you know what I mean I mean you can't do
much about a tornado but I bet we damn
sure would try wouldn't we oh my God we
would try our damn to figure out a way
to control the [__] weather
at least build a safer building
that the weather couldn't [__] take
out
but if we could stop that Tornado by God
we [__] would we'd stop every [__]
one of those tornadoes that that was
happening you damn well better bet we
would as a country and people like yeah
we gotta stop them tornadoes we can't
have them tornadoes just Mass murdering
people all over the place [__] it's
crazy
oh but guns oh man listen I know I know
that you have to dodge a few bullets
okay a couple times a week but listen
this is an American right that we're
talking about here
this is this is a constitutional right
even though it doesn't actually say it
in the Constitution it doesn't say it in
the Constitution it says some [__] that
we make up
that we [__] misinterpret
[__] out of here this nonsense
hell I hope gen Z keeps yelling and
screaming and they keep at it
I hope they keep at it now that is that
that video is actually was posted for
March of our lines March for our lives
which is an organization that was formed
by David Hogg and his classmates after
um
uh him and his classmates were gunned
down
and shot at
victims of a mass shooting
at Stoneman Douglas High School
um
I have school-aged children
it worries me every [__] day when I
send them to school
every [__] day
and it doesn't matter which campus they
go to you know I think well maybe this
this campus now that they're at you know
they get older they go to they go to a
middle school and then they go to high
school
I think maybe that camp is a little more
secure
from guns
and you walk in these buildings and the
new ones the new schools that they build
they build they build with the idea in
mind that someone's gonna come and
murder these people in this building
they designed the building that way
can you [__] imagine this
think about that for a second
they're designing the brand new skills
that they build to make sure that
when someone does come in with a gun
they kill less people
they use design design schools because
like where the bathrooms were placed
what it looked like
you know how are you gonna heat and cool
it you know what I mean like maybe the
geography
you know of of the space that it's gonna
be in
yeah
they never not not not until the
Republicans
got rid of the assault weapons ban did
they start focusing on making sure that
schools are designed
that schools are designed to fend off a
mass shooter
never and never had we thought about
that before in school design elementary
middle school high school college
campuses
and now when they're building those [__]
when they build churches or anything
else
they have that in mind oh my God surely
someone it's America
it's America surely someone's gonna come
in here and try to murder mass murder
people because you know Republicans
because we gotta have our guns we got to
make sure not only that we have our guns
that we have them easy access no
background checks [__] like I said you
don't have to have money you just have
to have a credit card
you ain't that money to buy a gun
in some states Texas you don't have to
have [__] money it's going with a
credit card
you can get it they'll give you all
kinds of [__] for free you know I'd pay
anything
oh Tony you have to pay your credit card
bill yeah okay
I'm sure the credit card company's still
trying to [__] get their money from
that kid in Uvalde after he killed
himself [__] out of here
pluck your head out of your ass okay and
realize realize that this is a
republican problem that we have the
Republican Nazis
are the problem
did you hear this kid
in this video this young man who's
sitting in a room with the rest of his
classmates mates
because Republicans won't do [__] about
[__] on guns
laugh at them mock them when they go and
they ask them to do something mock them
laugh at them
hmm
foreign
and we're supposed to take Mitt Romney
seriously
we're supposed to take we're supposed to
take Chris Christie seriously is that
what we're supposed to do
you know what we're supposed to do
no thank you I'll pass
I'll take a pass on on any Republican
who is affiliated with the with the
America First Nazi party I'll take a
pass on any any kind of thing that they
say that is is serious
okay
I'll take a pass on that
um I got another uh clip here and I I
thought I had it I thought I had it
available and it's a clip
of a congressman
absolutely destroying
the Republicans on this Hunter Biden
talking point I told you yeah I told you
the other day Daniel Goldman and Dana
Goldman was gonna get and get this oh
well looky what we have here
wouldn't you know it's about goddamn
time oh he's acting like he's got his
own show now this guy this [__] guy
acting like he's got his own goddamn
show now how are you uh the guy with the
last name Sanji I mean your your mic's
not working it doesn't seem
no it's not working see this see he
can't get his bike to work guys got his
own show got his own show now yeah he's
like I'm out
oh my God are you guys ready for what
was that live it's coming up you got
about seven minutes just just over seven
minutes before what was what was that
live happens uh with with the guy with
the last name Sanchez oh my God that's a
that's a throwback Royale says
chips and Giggles do you remember when
we just calling ships and giggles oh I
wonder I wonder if chips and Giggles
those chips and Giggles have his uh his
mic ah his mic's working
welcome welcome chips and giggles
so what are you talking about today
uh I'm gonna talk a little bit of mitt a
little bit of mitt you know I just I
just I just destroyed I just destroyed
Mitt Romney destroyed yeah he's a bit of
a [__] um a bit
he puts the bid in [__]
uh we're gonna be talking about Hunter
Biden he was just indicted yeah I heard
I heard on on some federal gun charges
this is probably all [__] but I mean
Biden's doj am I right oh man uh you
know you know wait a second are you
telling me that they couldn't get up
enough evidence to um indict him on
bribery charges for money that he was
taken this seems this seems wild man I
guess so I mean it really it seems like
all the things that Republicans are
saying about the Biden money is all wise
oh it's all projection oh man that's uh
hopefully there's a couple clips from
yesterday's committee hearings uh
Moskowitz yeah yeah which I was just
trying to find those just trying to find
this I'll let you play them on your
shoes all right all right I'll let you
have those all right well anyway I'm
gonna head out just wanted to come in
say hello see if your mic worked is that
what yeah you know it's good and you win
an audio test to do a mic check live you
know right right do I [__] it we'll do
it live when you and your you and your
uh
by the way people seem to really like
the Bill O'Reilly uh we'll do a live bit
really it's a good one man I see
comments people are like oh I love the
Bill O'Reilly thing as [__] up as Bill
O'Reilly is it's a classic moment in in
TV history
absolutely absolutely you can't get much
better than that whoa I mean he's
scrolling faster huh I don't know that's
on my feed that's on my feet I have no
idea what's going on no no you will
definitely be demonetized okay yo I'm
not gonna play it I'm not gonna play it
here let's see um um I was gonna well
okay I'll give you the I'll let you add
the uh mosque away and everyone you
gotta have her man no no no you guys
gotta go watch go watch uh what was that
line because this Moskowitz clip and
this Goldman clip you gotta see and I I
said this yesterday I was like look I
can't wait for for them to do these
impeachment inquiries and the reason why
is because people like Moskowitz and
Daniel Goldman are gonna [__] burn
Republicans to the ground and they did
it already like they oh yeah like before
the afternoon was out after I said that
they were gonna burn them to the ground
they're already burning them oh yeah
there's a full-on full-on roast
happening right now
um all right I gotta I gotta get a
couple Clips ready but I will go get
your Clips ready everyone um Gabe
Sanchez what was that live right after
this year just hit 10K did you really I
just well that's awesome
I wasn't sure yet and I think we hit 18.
hey Johnny Michael's podcast is 18 you
hit 10 same day two two two uh uh good
Milestones two peas in a pod everyone
stick around for what was that line with
Gabe Sanchez he's got a lot of Clips to
show you I want to show you a clip here
while he's get the hell out of here
would you please I want to shut up I
want to show my audience a clip of trump
cheating at golf get the hell out of
here
all right everybody I want to show you
this clip of the Trump cheating it's
been going around
um this is more of like the uh the
bobert type Clips you know what I mean
uh from the um from the theater it
really doesn't matter it doesn't really
matter in the in really in the context
of the clip but what matters is like the
hypocrisy of it all you know what I mean
like this guy runs around acting like
he's some kind of golf legend
he says he's won gazillions of [__]
club championships and all that stuff no
he hasn't he's done it because he's
cheated here's a [__] clip of trump
recently putting on a green now I don't
play [__] golf that much I've never
I've never play I played golf maybe two
or three times in my life and I'm
[__] horrible at it I'm horrible at
it and it's probably because I've only
played a couple times in my [__] life
but I I know when someone's cheating
even though if I don't know the game
here's here's Trump here's Trump uh
putting on the green watch this [__]
um uh that that does that seems like
cheating let's watch it again let's
watch again that seems like oh oh yeah
he would yeah he would she try to win
hmm huh seems like seems hypocritical to
me again again it's it's not the clip in
and of itself it's the [__] hypocrisy
of it all right uh some people are
talking about the hunter Biden
indictment in the um in the chat it's
breaking news which it is breaking news
uh Hunter Biden has been apparently
indicted on federal gun charges
woohoo good job it's a good thing I'm
not voting for Hunter Biden huh
it's a good thing I'm not voting for
Hunter Biden let me tell you
um apparently enter Biden has been
indicted on Federal Trade let's see if
we can find the uh the indictment here
oh man he's at the top of the list on on
Twitter uh let's see here it is uh Kyle
Chaney's got it here and just in uh
Hunter Biden has been indicted on three
charges related to false statements and
purchasing of a firearm oh man oh man
yeah Republicans should be pissed off
about this you know what I mean the two
eight Bros should be really mad that
anyone even had to ask him a question
right I mean really honestly it the
Republicans don't even want you to have
to ask a question to get a gun right I
mean they should be [__] they should
be really pissed that Hunter Biden is
charged with these with these three
felony
yeah Firearms charges
yeah that's what I would think but
they're not gonna be because they're
[__] hypocrites
they're [__] Hypocrites just like
Mitt Romney and Donald Trump they're
[__] hypocrites
and Lauren bobert the like
um but again you know it's a good thing
I I never planned on voting for uh
Hunter Biden let's see now Hunter Biden
face is a maximum of 25 years it
convicted
though would be unlikely and then the
reason why it would be unlikely is
because he doesn't have a prior criminal
history in the federal system so they're
not going to throw him a maximum of 25
years at him
um if and when other charges come
they're likely to be in other districts
California and DC because apparently
he's purchased it looks like he's
purchased these
um you know throughout the country one
just in one spot but breaking news uh if
you plan on voting for Hunter Biden you
might want to reconsider it
uh you know the best part about this you
know best part about this
is if Joe Biden is so corrupt and Hunter
Biden is so corrupt he would [__]
pardon him right now
and right now you need to stick around
here on YouTube and twitch you need to
stick around right here right now
because Gabe Sanchez what was that live
coming right at you if you're on YouTube
and twitch don't go anywhere what was
that live and we'll be here the same
time same place tomorrow and James
Gabe's gonna join me for bonehead of the
week so don't forget to come back here
same time same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon